bismillah alhamdulillah assalamualaikum
greetings of peace to everybody hope you
all are doing well I'm going to touch
upon a few things in this video I think
are very very important one I'm going to
talk about the judo match that happened
Olympics between the Egyptian and the
Israeli and from there I'm gonna tell
about disturbing a very disturbing post
that came after this shortly after this
all that more in this video all right
let's get right into it the judo match
at the Olympics and what happens the
Egyptian fighter loses refused to shake
the hands and my opinion is he should
have shook his hand he should have shook
his hand but I know what I was thinking
deeper you know you flick what you you
know you usually you want to think like
what I'm not gonna get into the route to
what what really was his intention what
is it what it was but I would just you
know this is just for conversation I was
thinking that if I was to ask in an
Israeli Jew who's who's been on my
program a friend of mine me copilot
whose father was a general in the
Israeli army
his family was part of signing of the
Declaration of Independence really a
person of high standing there he
probably tell me that had it would
probably had something to do I'm
guessing with the oppression of the
Palestinian people the aggression the
apartheid state protesting this of
Israel that that's what what I'm
guessing
and probably rabbi Weiss who's been on
the Dean show who's been on my program
he probably tell me the same thing now
do I agree with him not shake it has no
you should have shook his hand I think
that's that's what I would have done
this is what I would have advocated for
any of my my black bills competing and I
would have took it reminds me of the the
verse in the Quran chapter 41 34 where
God Almighty is saying that good and
evil are not the same repel evil with
what is better and then the one whom you
might have had MDT with would become a
friend okay so we got that other way I
my opinion what I
he should have shook his hand let's move
on from there now the more alarming and
disturbing thing with some of the
comments that came after that and a
particular post that really was
something just hate-filled derogatory
bigoted and it was from someone in
particularly the martial arts community
the Brazilian Jujitsu community and I
wanted to speak out instead of just
being a silent voice I want it to be a
loud voice because if the people if we
when we see this hey we don't speak out
against it
hey breeds hate and no matter if you're
a small leader a big leader you're a
leader and especially someone who's
involved in martial arts you're helping
to grow in future generations to be men
of character not just learning how to
fight learning the art but also learning
how to be a better human being you need
to be a good example and this is totally
opposite to that so you guys are
probably like what's the pulse what's
this all about now before I get to that
something very interesting everything
happens for a reason another thing that
motivated me was that this individual in
the community in the jiu-jitsu community
this person actually fought against one
of my black belts isn't that ironic
professor Idrees my cousin also they
competed let's go to this match
it's like a very interesting feeling
with you yourself and your time to be
capable to respond a way to fight and
compete
that's not means a victory or defeat or
anything but just to be able to choose
to do it you know
so when I learned about that that they
actually competed they fought and
actually at the energy you could see
that my black belt either these he shook
his hand so shake the hand he shook his
hand no worries no problems is all good
and part of good sportsmanship yes let's
do it move on but this person and I'm
gonna get to this and and I and I wanna
we should always look for the good in
situations should always looked at
everything happens for a reason there's
got to be you cannot be pessimists we
have to be optimists and look that
hopefully through this this person can
get informed get educated we can try to
dispel some of the myths the
misconceptions and move on good can go
ahead and be accomplished from this
small evil that's taking place now this
gentleman who made this post it's very
disturbing post he says why are people
complaining about his disrespect we know
what his religion brings and it's hate
for Jews and Christians or should I say
anyone but a Muslim let's stop right
there we know what his religion brings I
mean this is very disturbing I mean to
go and insult over 1.7 billion human
beings all across the globe and
especially you know if you think about
the United Arab Emirates Abu Dhabi was
started there how many of the gracie's
have great relationship with the Muslims
there in that country
Brazilians Americans people from all
walks of life people who are training
jiu-jitsu
in different parts of the Muslim world
and we use this kind of to unify us and
here comes somebody spreading this hate
we shouldn't tolerate it it's not a
joking matter we should all condemn it
and
the other thing he talks about about the
hate that this individual is preaching
try to push it on like as if Muslims
hate Jews and Christians another fallacy
and they said we want to separate the
mother than the Christians is obviously
you're going to kill him and they saw it
coming so the Muslims went around giving
head scarves to the Christian women and
otherwise trying to disguise them and
they risk their lives to save the
Christian minority some propaganda that
I I really feel bad and sorry for people
like this who I fell victim to this you
know the Islamophobia machine we know
that it's a two hundred million dollar
bill annual business it's money bashing
Islam
bashing Muslims and this person's fell
victim to it but the question is how
long is he gonna remain a victim
especially after he sees this he can
grow from this or continue to remain
ignorant so let's start with the first
part we know what his religion brings I
mean I you see this individual wearing a
Muhammad Ali's t-shirt let's start with
that what did it bring for the American
hero the Muslim American hero who a
quarter of a million people were
affected by his charity he wanted helped
those American hostages get released he
was out there serving humanity helping
humanity he's a he's a legend he's a
legacy and he was a Muslim and he was a
Muslim Muhammad Ali wearing his shirt
let's move on from there the hating of
Jews and Christian we know that as a
Muslim man you're allowed to marry a
Christian or a Jew
I mean how ironic is that you know you
would you would love if the really a
love/hate relationship can you imagine
if this if this was true you'd have to
hate the one you love your your wife
this would be something impossible to do
and it's crazy and it's not a joking
matter but you do have this ignorant
that's prevalent misinformation and we
know that during the Inquisition's
and many Jewish academics will come out
historians they know that Jews fled from
persecution to Muslim lands and so did
Christians open arms they'll welcome
even during the Holocaust so this is
something absurd it's disturbing
it's wrong well look I'm actually
interestingly enough as an Orthodox Jew
a great champion of Islam the fact is
that the Jewish community has a real
debt to the Islamic community because
when we were kicked out of Catholic
Spain in 1492 when we were kicked out of
Catholic Portugal I think in 1503 it was
the Muslims who took the Jews in that's
why their Jewish communities in the
Islamic world till this very day the
Islamic community the Jewish community
of Istanbul dates from then it was it
was specifically countries and not
beyond the Ottoman Empire where Jews
were tolerated and they were welcomed in
and they play they pay to jizya there
was a poll tax they paid but they were
never persecuted there wasn't the
Holocaust in the Islamic world the fact
is the Jews and Muslims have so much in
common
I've been out to a supper club with
Maria Parr Sheva my girlfriend missed a
Friday night in New York City around
11:30 we boarded the train on Canal
Street on glass car in the queue it
happened aboard the Q train at 11:30 on
Friday night Walter and three of his
friends were heading home after a
Hanukkah party in Manhattan when he
turned to another group of riders said
Abby Annika like happy attic of my
friends like something to that effect
and almost immediately you see the look
in this guy's face you killed him you
killed Jesus you killed him on Hanukkah
you dirty Jew you effing Jew when Hasan
Askari another passenger tried to help
he was beaten up to sounds the only
person to try and help us at all
everybody runs to the back of a car it
was pretty shocking to see something
like that happening you know you usually
don't expect something like that to go
on in the chain here we have freedom of
speech and freedom of religion and what
I've seen this Friday night it's just
put my spirits down that guy Hasan my
girlfriend and me and my best friend
might have been beaten to death on that
train if he hadn't jumped in and helped
us an Islamic teaches you to be you know
helpful to your fellow man to be
courteous no one else helped us except a
son no one else on the train a
muslim-american saved us when our own
people were on the train and didn't do
anything and when everyone else's people
on the train do anything someone who in
the media often gets painted as the
enemy of Israel and the Jews you know
this is a Bangladeshi Sunni Muslim this
is someone that jumped in he knew we
were Jews to help us hopefully this will
reach a lot of people and it will change
the way people view each other it would
change the way people act toward one
another
he goes on to say that Muslims kill
innocence through suicide bombing and
terrorism let's let's move on from there
we're gonna see what the experts have to
say we're gonna see what the statistics
are you know that the FBI statistics
report then 95% of terrorist attacks
from these years were done by
non-muslims did you know that over a
thousand terrorist attacks in the last
five years and less than 2% of those
were done by Muslims and I even get
hesitant to say I get weary when you say
by Muslims because we know when we look
at you know some of these recent events
that have happened if these people were
following Islam they wouldn't be doing
such attacks because there's a profound
statement in the Quran and even before I
get to the statement we see that Muslim
it's not supposed to be in a nightclub
owning that nightclub smoking dope
smoking the ganja drinking doing all of
these these things that are opposite to
Islam and you find these people who have
done such acts the small fringe element
that the media portrays like their
exemplary Muslims if they were
implementing Islam they wouldn't be in a
nightclub they wouldn't be smoking drugs
doing drugs drinking party and doing all
of these things hurting innocent people
this is totally the antithesis to Islam
it's very clear and there's a I want you
to remember this is this verse chapter 5
verse 32 in the Quran
there's no Constitution like it there is
no scripture like it anywhere in the
world says killing one innocent human
being is after you as if you kill the
world saving one innocent life is as if
you save the world let's continue on did
you know that with the over 140,000
terrorist attacks since 1970 this would
still equal I mean that's 140,000 since
1970 and if you add how many Muslims
those who claim to have been Muslim you
want to link back to to being Muslim
less than 0.009 percent
to look at the facts and follow the
fiction so when we add that up zero
point zero zero nine percent French
element and then you and then you if you
want to make that with the single daddy
with a single digits you want to
calculate the okay now Muslims are
terrorists but now not all terrorism uh
some Muslims are terrorists yada yada
yada then let's look at this logic why
don't we take that same logic and put it
to something that's more logical if you
look at of the recent Nobel Prize peace
winners you would have five out of the
twelve so according to that logic all
Muslims should be peace makers because
they're winning the Nobel Peace Prize it
gets more interesting I mean the facts
enlighten the mind they opened the
hearts knowledge is key education that's
what the Deen shows about we cover all
these things you can go the Deen show
com let me continue on you know there
was a study carried out by the
University of North Carolina and it
showed that less than zero point zero
zero two percent of Americans killed
since 9/11 were killed by Muslim
terrorists and again if these people are
following Islam they wouldn't be doing
any terrorist terrorism as far as
connecting innocent men women children
of course you have a god-given right to
defend yourself but wrecking havoc in
the land and killing innocents this is
totally forbidden in Islam now let's
verse that and compare that to consumer
safety reports and seeing how many they
say people were killed since then by
their TV by their furniture I mean if
you could look at toddlers with a gun
you have more of a chance getting killed
by by a toddler with a gun by lightning
or by your furniture than you do so
Muslim terrorists and you've been
spooked I mean you're afraid obviously
the the Islamic obeah machine two
hundred million dollar annually is a
business frightening you the boogeyman
is coming to get you and you get scared
you get spooked and many intelligent
people are seeing beyond this ignorant
people are getting in for
if they're open-minded if they're
sincerely looking for the true because
seek and you shall find now we know we
that we don't blame as logical human
beings we don't blame the car
manufacturer for a drunk driver so you
always have crazy individuals you have
this in every religion you had 355 mass
shootings in 2015 you had three of those
that were again connected back to
someone being a Muslim background but
you didn't hear the person's faith being
mentioned his ideology usually it's like
okay is this guy sick deranged what's
going on and you when you dig deep into
these people's lives that have done
these things that you claimed we're
Muslim you see that they had some really
psychological problems sociopaths sick
deranged
evil acts and Islam condemns it we
condemn it the common mantra is why
don't Muslims condemn if we don't have
the platform nor the mic we don't own
the Fox News my friend now again we're
analyzing looking at his really
disturbing hateful bigoted post
dismantling it one by one using logic
reasoning facts not fiction and suicide
he mentioned suicide bombing this has
nothing to do with Islam it's clearly
mentioned in the Koran that killing
yourself is something that's forbidden
throwing yourself into destruction and
this is something a consensus among the
scholars Muslim scholars as suicide is
something that is forbidden so there's
no suicide in Islam you know a lot of
these things came and why don't we go to
the experts I mean look and research and
look in and see what the experts are
saying about this my opinion is
injustice humiliation oppression that is
are the most common causes some people
claim that religion motivates terrorists
however the academic research of dr.
Robert Pape has proved the claim to be
false
what I did is I collected the first
complete database of every suicide
terrorist attack around the world since
1980 the first version of this database
was published a few years ago and I went
from 1980 to 2003 I think of that is
like the pre Iraq database and then the
second version from 2004 on think of
that is the data that's happened since
Iraq and what the data shows quite
clearly is that the principal cause of
suicide terrorism is foreign occupation
in that period from 1980 to 2003 there
were 315 completed suicide terrorist
attacks by 462 suicide terrorists who
actually killed themselves I don't mean
attempts these are people who actually
killed themselves the world leader
during that 24 year period was not an
Islamic group at all they're the Tamil
Tigers in Sri Lanka the Tamil Tigers are
a Marxist group a secular group a Hindu
group in fact over half of those 462
suicide attackers were purely secular
because you see many Muslim suicide
terrorist groups are also pure purely
secular such as the PKK in Turkey the
PKK in Turkey
which did numerous suicide attacks in
the 1990s is again a Marxist read anti
religious suicide terrorist group
because you see if Islam as sort of a
radical religion or if it were just
radical Muslims doing this then what you
would expect is sort of this thin veneer
of suicide attack kind of scattered all
around the world you would expect that
oh there's 1.4 billion Muslims you know
there's this teeny tiny fringe of
Muslims kind of everywhere who'd be
willing to do suicide attack but that's
not the way the data looks it's really
concentrated and it's really
concentrated in occupations
and you go to these people I mean not to
FoxNews and you know that's what causes
radical ization when you self educate
then you're reading the headlines and
you know snippet here snippet there and
then you create a fulfill a
self-fulfilling prophecy in your head
you know you're coming
at the Quran looking at things out of
context you're getting your information
from Islamophobes you become a Slama
form you become a radical you start
radicalizing your students I mean this
needs to stop you we you know we hope
that the individual grows out of this we
dispel oui oui De Smet with dismantling
this one by one we got one more to go he
talked about that Muslim man they behead
their wives how ridiculous I mean yeah
it's just really absurd if a man was to
do that to to behead his wife he the
Islamic Court would put him to dehii be
executed I mean so that's done with that
what else do we have that he talks about
he said he didn't shake his hand ah
complain about the real problem his
religion and his leaders okay so we take
it back it's a very nice shirt that the
mr. the guy is wearing from Hamid Ali
like to use this example because this is
an exemplary Muslim and there are a lot
of those he's someone that was living
Islam personified Islam through his
actions you're wearing his shirt my
friend he was an American Muslim hero
and Islam through the facts that I just
quoted clearly is opposite to what
people like yourself are thinking I
really encourage you to watch the Deen
show to look more into this you know
this is something that is is very
disturbing you've insulted over 1.7
billion human beings I'd like for others
you Jitsu teachers and instructors who
see this to come out and condemn you
know people like this like you can
either grow from this come out should
apologize we can shake hands we can move
forward we can grow from this just like
the man who reminds me who who where
derogatory shirt
in Arizona and then he went into the
mosque afterwards he was in Heder he was
a hater but he got to ask the tough
tough questions to the Muslims
he made a human connections and then
respect for the Islamic people know what
I know now since I have talked to them
and spoke with them no no I would not do
that again just because I don't want to
offend or hurt those people he came out
a reformed man and I have hope I hope I
have hope for Humanity I have hope for
this individual he can come out even
better from this or I mean sadly I hope
he doesn't remain in that hole of
ignorance because he's only gonna bring
design he's only he's only gonna hurt
himself his heart his humanity and and
for those people who are under him but
let me finish off with this I mean you
do have issues I mean what can be the
cause I mean we have to get to the root
of the problem and then do some
self-evaluation and we've dispelled this
myth about Islam you know someone
picking up the Quran and because they
did that you know now there's suicide
bombers they're terrorists no I I just
gave you the facts we wanted to see it
again look at it again it's very clear
but if we look at for instance just
let's let's you let's listen let's see
Iraq for a second let's look to that the
13 years of sanctions you know the death
of 1 million children over the course of
13 years imagine you've had innocent I
mean innocent life there here it's it's
all the same as innocent life you've had
2000 2003 an invasion based on false
premises and lies
do you remember that and then
conservative I mean low numbers to
estimate a hundred seventy thousand
innocent people had died from this this
war you know a reliable sword The Lancet
puts it at over seven hundred sixty
thousand innocent human beings you know
you go into a country you exploit his
resources flip it upside down turn it
into a ghetto imagine if that happened
here in America how many terrorists
would have that had created you know
there was a headline in a popular
newspaper the onion says newbomb able to
create a thousand new terrorist
one blast when these bombs are dropped
in someone's backyard is someone's
wedding drone attacks all these things
that imagine if it was happening here
you know these people they they end up
losing themselves you know you get your
whole family destroyed again Islam
doesn't condone any Aslam condemns
killing the innocent when men women and
children you don't reciprocate this kind
of evil with evil and as I quoted the
diverse and there's so much
self-reflection that we need to do and
to see that war mongering this war
machine this is not bringing about any
good right and this is the root of the
cause of the problem and you hear a lot
about this isis daesh you know these
people are killing more muslims did you
know that they're killing more muslims
you just had this event in pakistan
where's the the pray for pakistan in
seven and seventy and some people had
died it seems like muslim blood is cheap
and remember a muslim is simply one who
submits to the will of god you know what
is Islam brought it it is brought that
individual to have peace with his
creator peace within himself peace with
humanity and society in a person who has
peace in himself he's not expounding
this hate rhetoric and it goes down to a
deeper problem within oneself that
people have when they're full of this
hate they're they're taught this hate
they end up breeding more hate and we
that's where we have to as a community
shut this does hate rhetoric down we
have to condemn this again insulting
over 1.7 billion human beings all across
the world you can't separate the two
when you say F Sharia like saying F the
Bible F when you insult you you want to
get to know someone you come in and you
assault his mother I mean what that's
not the whole essence of freedom of
speech my friends you know the for the
founding forefathers of this country
didn't make freedom of speech based on
those premises and you insult this way
of life that brings peace to to so many
people's hearts I mean you know part of
Islam is the deep love and reverence for
Jesus peace be upon him and his Blessed
Mother Mary there's a whole chapter
named after her in the Koran if you got
to know this I mean he was
that there is so many more commonalities
there are so many more commonalities
between Muslims and Jews and Christians
and people the good in humans have
forced them to look beyond this hate and
have investigated them citizen and and
what kind of people accept Islam women
particularly why would they accept Islam
if it was preaching these kind these
evil things but no they see the opposite
what was the difference is that they've
investigated they've looked into it
they've taken a analytical scientific
approach they've seen like hold on man
we've been fed fairy tales fictions
false propaganda and many people we see
that Islam is the fastest growing second
largest religion in the world stop going
anywhere Christians are going anywhere
so we need to learn to work together to
make society to make the world a better
place and to teach our students and
those under us you know you have I often
give the example of my oggi
the karate kid when he was teaching his
student daniel-san not just fighting
with some principles for life and then
you had Cobra Kai you want to be Cobra
Kai you want to be my Aggie my friend
you want to be somebody who's spreading
hate or love understanding you got to
pick a side and if you continue to stay
on that side you'll just bring more
destruction upon your heart your soul
your soul you'll be a a person who will
just be angry and bitter and you'll lose
so many opportunities to make more
connections with more human beings to
develop more understanding and to live a
more fruitful and well-balanced life so
I hope that one day I can meet people
like this who've had a change of heart I
my door is open to come and sit and we
can discuss these matter matters like
two intelligent human beings not
insulting one another again you don't
get to making a human connection by
insulting someone's someones mother
someone's father someone's family but
this is something that's even more dear
to us this is way of life from the
Creator Islam submission to the will of
God submission to the crater not the
creation now I think I'd cover this
enough and I hope that we can grow from
this and I hope this person comes out
and really reflects on these ignorant
bigoted statements that the individual
made apologizes to to the over 1.7
billion people that he has he has
offended and all the people who are
working for jiu jitsu and see it growing
in this part of the world in the united
arab emirates people who who work there
who live live with muslims who who
experience the love and generosity of
muslims and the instructors people who
use this as a unifying factor let's not
let someone use it as a dividing factor
and divide us condemn it speak against
it if you if you like what we have to
say like this video and and hopefully
I'll look forward to this person growing
from this and I'm looking for the good
to come out of it I hope so I really do
I pray I pray for for him for humanity
that God guides us all to to peace and
purpose in life and so we can have good
relationships with the other and we can
eradicate this hate I end with quote
from Nelson Mandela who said people
aren't born hating they're taught to
hate we can teach them how to love and
that's through education this is the
important thing call us